and here she is Melania future first
lady now I actually have somewhat
milania's nudes up here and you know get
some Melania nudes yeah and so and some
people will say that this is crazy you
can look at her naked I don't think so
I think it's great you know I've wanted
to see most of the first lady's naked
and the idea that I now can and that
there's you know that there's tons of
options I'm actually looking at polar
bears yeah who have about two years left
to live hello
okay debbie downer a lot of people you
know we talked about inauguration day
and what this means for Donald Trump
what this means for the Republican Party
but let's all take a moment to think
about what this means for gold-digging
right this is a big day
if you're a young gold-digging
looking and watching this inauguration
today you're thinking look anything's
positive anything's possible when people
said the glass ceiling wasn't shattered
in this last alieve that it was this is
a possible prostitute in this in this
high of a position I mean it it is
dynamite and anything can happen there
another nude picture of Melania just
came up I think you're the bud I think
that might be a virus you have on there
cuz those are gonna keep coming yeah
there's a graphic